[Música]
[Aplausos]
voy a contar un cuento
un cuento clásico porque tiene un
príncipe
un rey
una madrastra
y un médico
mágico
lo que pasa que el cuento es histórico
esto sucedió hace 2500 años
moría el príncipe el principe antíoco en
su lecho de muerte y morían delante de
su padre el rey se lee con uno de los
generales de alejandro magno que se
repartieron el imperio y moría delante
de su amada madrastra
la bella extra tonic la mujer más bella
de alejandría tenían sólo 17 años era la
segunda mujer de ese elenco ya mayorcito
el médico uno de los más famosos de la
antigüedad era así estrato era así soto
naturalmente visitaba a domicilio le
tomaba el pulso todos los días
al pobre antíoco tenía un pulso muy
débil a lo cual contribuye sin duda las
sangrías que se le practicaban
se le aceleraba solamente cuando la
bella stratton y se pasaba por delante
la mujer más bella
incluso se sonrojaba a pesar de la
creciente anemia que le estaba
provocando era sis trató claro el rey se
leuco de un momento en que le dijo el
doctor o como se dijeran la época mi
hijo tiene solución o va a morir
rachel eu co
dijo era así estrato tu hijo puede vivir
si tú haces lo que yo te diga y mi padre
hace lo que sea por un hijo pues
divórciate de la bella stratton efe
dársela en matrimonio será un 14 y el
gesto pero lo hizo
y se casaron fueron muy felices vivieron
muchísimos años tuvieron cinco hijos y
son los antecesores de la reina
cleopatra la última de los ptolomeos
bien pues ya ha terminado la historia
del príncipe pero porque no he contado
una historia de princesas pues porque no
había muchas princesas
y las princesas no tenían maldeamores
las princesas tenían histeria y esto
dyster ya de dónde viene pues de veinte
siglos antes de cristo porque en los más
antiguos papiros que tenemos papiro de
ebers papiro de kaun atribuían al útero
esteros en griego histeria para todos
nosotros una movilidad era como un
organismo autónomo si se movía por aquí
hay me puede doler en el costado dolor
precordial en el pecho la garganta no me
llenó de aire eso hay que bajarlo y
ponerlo a su sitio los equipos eran
prácticos y entonces cómo se hace eso
pues muy fácil por vía nasal mediante
sustancias que se llaman en
otorrinolaringología repugnantes
o a trayéndolo desde abajo mediante
irrigaciones vaginales con sustancias
aromáticas de antigüedad casi 30 siglos
pues no señor no tanta antigüedad todas
las películas de época que han visto
ustedes cuando sale la damisela
escarlata o'hara o similar y le da a
esos válidos y se caen a alguien grita
las sales que traigan la sal las sales
son sustancias repugnantes que se han
utilizado en urgencias hasta hace muy
poco tiempo y los irrigador es vaginales
aromáticos se han vendido hasta casi
principios del siglo 20 los últimos ya
con música se podía con música si
efectivamente mientras se hacían las
irrigaciones bien esto ha tenido tanto
peso en la historia la historia de la
histeria que los griegos veredales pero
no no era un griego cualquiera lo hereda
hipócrates el padre de la medicina
en esta época sucintamente diré que la
teoría de la enfermedad se basaba en
cuatro humores y el equilibrio de los
cuatro humores era la salud los cuatros
moles eran la sangre la bilis negra la
bilis blanca y la flema y de ahí venían
los temperamentos a todos sucederle sana
colérico sanguíneo flemático melancólico
melano melanoma negro color bilis negra
esa era la causa esa era la causa de la
melancolía que aún seguimos utilizando
ese término actualmente como una
depresión de tipo grave pensaba
hipócrates
qué
la histeria se debía básicamente a una
corrupción uterina en la pensaba que el
útero estuviera dando vueltas por el
organismo pero si pensaba que la
ausencia de relaciones sexuales producía
esa corrupción u moral y que había que
tratar
hipócrates recomendaba el matrimonio
para las viudas y para las chicas
jóvenes que tenían síntomas histéricos
que antiguos no que movernos hasta hace
muy poco tiempo cuando había en españa
servicio militar obligatorio todo el
mundo sabía lo que le hacía falta a la
chica que tenía estos síntomas en cádiz
era un soldado y en san fernando era un
marinero que cuando había recambios es
decir que esto este concepto popular
histérico pero si esto lo hereda hasta
el propio freud muchos siglos después la
represión sexual es si todo tiene que
ver con el útero al final
hasta que se da algún pasito más un
pasito más
ya tenemos que llegar a galeno que
piensa que la corrupción evidentemente
sostiene todas las teorías hipocrática
pero le pasó la pelota también al género
masculino y que el hombre también team
histeria y tiene histeria por la teoría
o moral porque cuando el semen
se acumula y se corrompe
es un veneno
semeret en tu veneno es
decía galeno con lo cual ponía la
salvación de los pobres enfermos en sus
propias manos sin ningún tipo de
dificultad
al alcance de todos los fríos es
aún había psiquiatría aún no había
enfermedades mentales esta diferencia no
la hace ninguna historiador es más la
medicina está en él desde el punto de
vista psicológico absolutamente
paralizada durante más de mil años mil
años de oscuridad en los que suceden
cosas terribles cuando los enfermos
mentales son tratados como brujos sobre
todo las mujeres como brujas se publican
tratados como el martillo de las brujas
se queman cientos de miles de personas
durante mucho tiempo y hubo muy pocos
médicos valientes que se atrevieran
que se atrevieran a tratar a tratar lo
que eran enfermedades mentales a no ser
que todos ustedes crean en las brujas
sin la inquisición la mayoría de las
quemadas eran personas torturadas que
preferían una muerte rápida y enfermos
mentales en muchísimos casos entonces ya
hay médicos que empiezan a poner orden
en todo esto y este orden es muy
importante porque es la primera
definición
d
mal de amores eróticos el erotismo en
esta época no tenía el mismo sentido que
tiene actualmente no que muchas veces
roza lo pornográfico aquí eros es el
amor
cupido amor melancolía erótica pero la
importancia es la etiología es la
primera vez que dan con el virus o la
bacteria como hacemos ahora el origen de
estas enfermedades de los males de amor
citas es erótico en este sentido y este
tratado tiene es el tratado de la
esencia y curación del amor tiene otras
muchas virtudes se considera el primer
tratado de psiquiatría como tal que no
existía la especialidad europeo
y las descripciones clínicas que hacen
son perfectas ustedes están
familiarizados ahora con esquizofrenia
psicosis maníaco-depresiva trastorno
bipolar e psicópatas fobias obsesiones
en fin todo eso les suena a familiar por
lo menos les suena y ahí ya se empieza a
inventar la psiquiatría aunque en fin
tardamos mucho tiempo nosotros somos una
especialidad relativamente joven la
psiquiatría se separa de la medicina
interna a finales del siglo 19
prácticamente pero ya hemos sido
poniéndole nombre a toda la psicología
crece también y entonces también
empezamos a conocer los trastornos de la
personalidad y las enfermedades
relacionadas con el amor pero ya con una
nomenclatura concreta lo cual nos
plantea un problema me lo plantea a mí
por el título de esta comunicación
qué es lo que hay que curar
cuando sí y cuando no bueno hay que
poner algún límite aquí hemos puesto un
límite marítimo sería en vez de la
delgada línea roja es una delgada línea
más bien azul vamos a suponer que del
azul para arriba el cielo es lo no
tratable que no es digno de tratamiento
a pesar de que a lo mejor el sufrimiento
sea muy intenso porque si estamos
hablando de mal de amor es un abandono
conyugal una separación un divorcio el
novio lo que piense en cualquier
desastre el sufrimiento es inmenso es
muy intenso
diríamos tiene una depresión muy grande
esta persona no tiene ganas de comer y
de dormir está desesperada la vida no
tiene sentido sí pero a lo mejor esa
intensidad sintomatológica en el cielo
que indica salud mental indica que tiene
una elasticidad mental que le permite
reaccionar frente a una situación de
manera adecuada siempre que sea
proporcionada la intensidad la duración
etcétera
bueno la duración cuánta duración bueno
nosotros tenemos ya desde hace muchos
años criterios diagnósticos operativos
si eso se lo preguntan a un miembro de
la oms ahora le diría seis meses no son
seis meses porque sería un trastorno
adaptativo
seis meses la reacción depresiva irá irá
bajando y tal y si no baja entonces ya
es una depresión y nos metemos en el
charco del agua 2 y hay que tratar y
antes no no pero también depende como he
dicho del criterio diagnóstico por qué
piensen en otras situaciones una chica
alegre y dicharachera sociable que le
gustan los guateques le gusta salir con
chicos o con muchos chicos y es
tremendamente divertida
si me la diagnostica un cura párroco
es un furor uterino o es una ninfomanía
y diagnosticado por un psiquiatra lo
mejor no tiene ninguna de esas cosas
sirve para los hombres las llamadas
satiriasis es más o menos lo mismo podía
imaginar que de otra manera entonces
vamos a meternos debajo del agua que es
lo que vamos a tratar pues básicamente
básicamente lo que vemos en la práctica
cotidiana
lo más corriente son trastornos
depresivos trastornos de diferentes
intensidades y duraciones y después
trastornos que son más graves quizás
menos frecuentes pero graves los
antiguos llamaban para antiguos del
siglo diecinueve erotomanía psicosis
pasionales
qué quiere decir estos son trastornos
delirantes delirantes significa y
persistentes brillantes significa falso
es una idea falsa referida al amor en
este caso la persona que la sufre
está convencida del enamoramiento
profundo de otra persona hacia ella
los franceses muy finolis la llamaban la
psicosis de la vieja doncella los
españoles que son más brutos llevamos
psicosis de la solterona generalmente el
enamoramiento con alguien superior en
fin ya me entienden todo esto ha ido
cambiando ha ido cambiando mucho porque
en la actualidad la erotomanía es
extraordinariamente frecuente piensen en
artistas y jugadores de fútbol en team y
clubs de adoradores que no están
enfermos pero entre algunos de ellos y
aparece la erotomanía a quien pues una
chica que ha ido a ver a ricky martin al
concierto de sevilla se ha hecho un self
y con ricky y además tiene una foto que
pone para isabel con todo el cariño de
ricky martin que más prueba necesitas
para saber que lo ama estos tipos de
delirios
muchas veces evolucionan hacia un
encapsulamiento entonces la persona que
lo sufre lo sufre y lo sufre en silencio
otras veces son expansivos pasan a la
acción por eso se gastan tantísimo
dinero los famosos en guardaespaldas
porque realmente está esta es una
realidad una realidad que existe y que
no lo vemos cotidianamente prácticamente
hay otro tipo de delirio persistente que
a mí personalmente es el que más me
preocupa
es el delirio de celos que es el delirio
de celos bueno pues es un trastorno
delirante desde la idea de la
infidelidad de la pareja es falsa por
definición y este sujeto pues es un
sujeto ponte potencialmente muy
peligroso lo verán ustedes en todos los
informativos todos los días estamos
hablando de una patología corriente la
celopatía y en nuestro medio la
celopatía alcohólica probablemente la
más peligrosa se considera que casi un
30 por ciento de los crímenes y tal que
vemos están relacionados con el alcohol
hay patologías radice y más también
algunas que algunas parecen una especie
de contradicción se puede tener una
fobia no voy a hablar de toda la
patología psiquiátrica tranquilícese
fobia al amor se puede tener
phil o fobia hombre jovial amor no es al
revés no hay personas que tienen fobia
al amor y que si es una fobia pues una
fobia es un
temor irracional absolutamente
irracional que nos lleva a una conducta
equitativa de esa situación el que tiene
fobia a los ascensores no los va a [ __ ]
ni va a pasar por un túnel si tiene
fobia los túneles y si tiene fobia el
amor no querrá normaron enamorarse a lo
mejor porque tiene ya antecedentes tiene
algunas señales y no tiene es decir que
muchas veces es fácilmente comprensible
psicológicamente pero estamos hablando
de un hecho cotidiano y lo contrario
porque saben ustedes saben ustedes que
los asesinos en serie descuartizadores
la gente más deleznable que hay en las
prisiones del mundo son los que reciben
mayor cantidad de correo amoroso sacas
de correo y mayores mayor número de
peticiones vis-à-vis
bueno pues esto es una realidad he dicho
que hablar de la curación
hay una curación
popular
y la popular más popular no puede ser
amor con amor se quita si esto se
pudiera hacer en forma de receta como lo
hemos puesto aquí sería estupendo pero
eso no existe
el saber popular también dice que vaya a
una ferretería y se compre un clavo
porque un clavo con otro clavo se quita
y si no la frutería porque una mancha de
mora con otra mora se quita pero el
refranero popular no es estúpido es
decir cuando dicen esto es que tiene un
razón por lo menos en el 90% lo demás ya
queda en manos de profesionales en manos
de profesionales que tenemos que tratar
y le voy a resumir nuestros tratamientos
muy rápidamente
el tratamiento de la patología
diagnosticada es básicamente un
tratamiento biológico
estamos en 2018 y en tratamientos
psicológicos naturalmente la
afortunadamente los avances biológicos
de los últimos años son muy importantes
nunca hemos tenido
un arsenal terapéutico tan eficaz como
ahora igual que un arsenal psicológico
de terapias no piensen ustedes sabrán el
antiguo psicoanálisis eran cosas que se
pueden hacer todos los días
y técnicos muy cualificados psicólogos
clínicos muy calificados así como
terapias cognitivo-conductuales y
podemos tratar una gran cantidad de
casos
pero no todos pero no solamente no todos
sino que algunos preocupantemente no los
tratamos a lo mejor no tenemos aún la
tecnología suficiente no me quiero
guardar que ya los científicos han
descubierto el centro del amor el centro
del amor en el cerebro situados en la
mitad la cerebral que comparte otra
serie de actividades como las adicciones
etcétera y ya se están tratando con
terapias de estimulación inhibición y en
mí no me extrañaría yo no sé si lo voy a
ver o no o ustedes que una parte de los
tratamientos en el futuro más o menos
patológicos era un tratamiento
electromagnético no lo sé no quería
dejar de decirlo yo creo que en los
casos de amores patológicos dañinos
dañinos que cuesta la vida de las
personas hay que hacer una labor
preventiva y esta labor preventiva no
solamente hacen los políticos jueces
policías
etcétera no es que la tenemos que hacer
absolutamente las casi mil personas que
tenemos aquí cada uno dentro de su
ámbito se cambiaron políticos se cambia
eso se hace votando o lo que sea pero
tenemos que hacer algo y luego nosotros
tenemos que hacer algo personalmente es
una actitud intransigente frente al
maltrato intransigente frente a las
amenazas de muerte que todo el mundo las
oye y las comparten en las barras de los
padres y tenemos que ser muy
intransigentes porque la prevención se
hace antes del charco de sangre no
después de charco de sangre eso está en
nuestras manos gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]